un
[Musique]
enfant sur cinq est victime de violences
sexuelles oui vous avez bien entendu 20
% des enfants sont victimes de violences
sexuelles en europe et pourtant on n'en
parle pas ces petites victimes sont
indicibles et pourtant si on change de
regard on peut voir
je suis véronique sages-femmes sexologue
et mère de trois enfants je suis hélène
avocate et mère de deux enfants
en ou formant sur ce sujet nous avons
porter un nouveau regard sur les
personnes victimes de violences
sexuelles
en tant que parents nous avons été
décontenancés par le sujet en tant que
professionnels nous avons été
bouleversés et nous avons changé nos
pratiques en tant que citoyenne nous
avons décidé de devenir actrice de
l'éveil des consciences
et si nous prenons la parole ce soir
c'est quand nous avons l'espoir de vous
faire porter à nouveau regard sur les
personnes victimes de violences
sexuelles afin de rendre visibles les
violences sexuelles sur mineurs
dans cette classe de 25 enfants de cp
cinq enfants sont victimes
nous avons choisi de vous parler de
jeanne
jama six ans elle apprend à lire et à
écrire c'est une petite fille joyeuse
enfin en apparence
ses parents divorcent ils sont
préoccupés par leurs problèmes
j'en ai gardé par ses grands parents
tous les mercredis et très souvent le
week-end
son grand-père la viole tous les
mercredis et très souvent le week-end
mamie prépare le repas elle est dans la
cuisine et c'est à ce moment précis que
jeanne que papy emmène jane dans le
salon
il s'assied avec elle sur le canapé
glisse à main sur sa cuisse la remonte
sous sa jupe dans sa culotte et
introduit son doigt dans le vagin de
cette petite fille de 6 ans
jeanne ne dit rien elle ne peut rien
dire
elle ne peut ni crier ni fuir elle est
sidéré
la sidération est un mécanisme psychique
mis en place par le cerveau pour faire
face à un risque vital d'arrêt cardiaque
le non sens de la violence son caractère
impensable empêche toute représentation
mentale la vie psychique s'arrête il n'y
a plus d'accès à la pensée à la parole
c'est le vide il n'y a plus qu'un état
de stress extrême
quand jeanne revient dans la cuisine
mami lui donne toujours un carré de
chocolat c'est bizarre un carré de
chocolat avant de manger
jane parle à sa tante pauline de ce que
lui fait son grand père
pauli lui dis qu'il ne faut rien dire
papier tellement gentil et puis ça va
détruire la famille et qui gardera
jeanne le mercredi
alors jeanne ne parle pas mais jeanne
oublie
jeanne oubli mais son corps parle
c'est à ce moment précis que les
cauchemars ont commencé que les notes
ont chuté à l'école que les grosses
colères sont apparus que les crises de
boulimie sont devenues quotidiennes au
point de prendre cinq kilos en trois
mois et pourtant jeanne ne se souvient
plus de rien
59% des victimes de violences sexuelles
dans l'enfance ont des périodes
d'amnésie il s'agit d'un mécanisme
dissociatif de sauvegarde que le cerveau
déclenché pour se protéger de la terreur
du stress extrême engendrés par les
violences il entraîne des troubles de la
mémoire à long terme
et si la tante de jeanne l'avait aidé à
libérer sa parole et si son institutrice
étaient questionnés sur la chute brutale
de ses résultats scolaires et si son
pédiatre s'était interrogé sur une telle
prise de poids et s'il avait changé de
regard pour pouvoir voir
ses parents divorcent ça doit être ça
l'explication
aujourd'hui jeanne à 7 ans c'est samedi
elle est ravie d'aller au poney club
elle brosse son poney préféré dans son
box quand elle constate une clé sur son
arrière train
elle appelle son moniteur pour lui
montrer le moniteur la rassure cette
plaie ce n'est rien de grave
le moniteur s'approche très près de
jeanne
tout sa poitrine
ses fesses et frotte son sexe contre le
sien
jeanne ne peut pas bouger elle a peur
elle veut que ça s'arrête
elle se laisse faire
quand il quitte le box le moniteur lui
dit tu as aimé ça c'est pour ça que tu
m'appeler mais c'est notre petit secret
sur le chemin de la maison jeanne son
voeu est ce qu'elle n'est pas un peu
responsable de ce qui vient de se passer
son corps la dégoûte n'arrive plus à
sortir de la douche mamans sont
inquiètes que se passe-t-il jeanne
et jeanne fini par dire le moniteur et
caresse la peur
le dégoût
maman conduit immédiatement jacquot
jeanne au commissariat après une longue
attente elle est entendue par un
policier il lui pose beaucoup de
questions il ya même des mots qu'elle ne
comprend pas est ce que oui ou non vous
étiez seul dans les écuries je n'en sais
rien à ce qu'il était violent est ce
qu'il t'a menacée
est-ce qu'il était en érection en
érection mais qu'est ce que c'est est-ce
que je suis idiote de ne pas connaître
ce mot
jane sera entendu par un expert
psychologue puis réentendue par un
policier qui lui proposera les mêmes
questions ce qu'elles donnent de
mauvaises réponses
le policier trouve qu'il ya beaucoup
d'incohérences dans les différentes
versions de jeanne calment et en colère
elle n'a fait que dire la vérité
- 2 6 % des enfants mentent lorsqu'ils
dénoncent des faits de violence sexuelle
-2 6% en revanche le discours de
l'enfant peut être très facilement
polluée si sa parole est mal recueilli
cela peut conduire à de fausses
allégations involontaire
al'inverse des études montrent que même
des enfants de 3 ans qui font un récit
libre donne des informations
habituellement exact
15 mois se sont écoulés quand un
courrier arrive dans la boîte aux
lettres avis de classement sans suite le
moniteur a nié les faits il n'y a pas de
preuves matérielles bad adn et la parole
de jeanne est devenu inaudible
la plupart des violences sexuelles se
déroule sans témoin dans un huit clos
les preuves matérielles disparaissent
rapidement le viol est souvent un crime
parfait
environ 10% des viols feront l'objet
d'un dépôt de plainte seul 1% des viols
donneront lieu à une condamnation
et si le policier avaient été formés à
l'audition de l'enfant si la police et
la justice étaient capables de porter un
autre regard sur la parole de l'enfant
pour pouvoir voir pour pouvoir entendre
pouvoir voir et pour pouvoir rendre
visible l'agression subie par gêne
aujourd'hui jeanne à 16 ans elle est
amoureuse de paul sortent ensemble
depuis trois mois ce soir jeanne fête
son anniversaire
au cours de la soirée paul emmènera dans
l'une des chambres de la maison il
embrasse il commence à la caresser elle
dit non mais soudainement l'attitude de
paul change il devient brutale baisse la
culotte de jardel à pénètre violemment
jallet tétanisés elle ne ressent rien ni
douleur ni plaisir
jane parle à sa copine lucie de ce qui
vient de se passer pourquoi t'as pas
crié pourquoi tu t'es pas enfuie on
était juste en bas
je ne sais pas pourquoi elle ne s'est
pas enfui pourquoi elle n'a pas cris est
la honte elle culpabilise
de cet épisode de violence jeanne leur
parlera jamais elle voudrait que cette
agression soit invisible elle veut juste
être une adolescente comme les autres
mais son corps parle à nouveau elle
entre dans une phase dépressive qui
durera un an
une femme qui a été victime de violences
sexuelles et physiques dans l'enfance à
dix neuf fois plus de chances d'être
victimes de violence conjugale et
sexuelle à l'âge adulte
et si la copie l'uci avait compris
jeanne et si le médecin traitant
s'étaient interrogés sur la dépression
de jade et si vous avez porter un autre
regard pour pouvoir voir
aujourd'hui jeanne à 35 ans elle est
mère de deux enfants elle a divorcé deux
fois a été licencié trois fois et vient
de déposer plainte pour violence
conjugale contre son nouveau compagnon
elle a des soucis de santé maladies auto
immunes
obésité hypertension qui sauvèrent
troubles dépressifs troubles du sommeil
elles ne s'aiment pas elle manque de
confiance en elle
elle voudrait bien souvent disparaître
devenir invisibles et pourtant
si la tante de jeanne son institutrice
son pédiatre le policier le médecin
traitant le lac au pin avait porté à
notre regard pour pouvoir voir
alors j'en aurais probablement osé
parler l aurez compris ce qui se passait
pour elle on aurait pu lui proposer des
soins probablement une vie meilleure
nous avons choisi de vous parler de
jeanne
mais dans cette classe de cp de 25
enfants nous aurions pu vous parler de
rémy qui a été victime de son beau-père
qui l'obligé à regarder de la
pornographie et le forcer à le masturber
rémy n'a trouvé de soulagement quand se
suicidant il n'avait que 17 ans son
agression est resté totalement invisible
nous aurions pu vous parler d' amélie
qui a été victime de son père médecin
sous couvert d'examen médical il l'a
violé tous les jours à 49 ans amélie a
voulu déposer plainte mais les faits
sont prescrits
son agression est resté invisible pour
la justice
nous aurions également pu vous parler de
gabriel qui a été victime d' appât être
d'après d'un prêtre pédophile
de 6 à 12 ans ni le prêtre auquel il
s'est confié ni ses parents ne l'ont cru
son agression est resté totalement
invisible pour sa famille et pour
l'église
nous aurions pu vous parler de claire
qui a été agressée sexuellement par un
camarade de classe
forte heureusement pour claire ses
parents l'ont cru elle a bénéficié d'une
prise en charge adaptée après une
période difficile elle a pu reprendre le
cours de sa vie aujourd'hui elle va bien
pour pouvoir aider une personne victime
il faut la rendre visible
il faut concevoir l'ampleur du phénomène
savoir qu'il existe dans tous les
milieux
comprendre qu'il est majeur chez les
enfants
entendre que les mécanismes de
sauvegarde psychiques peuvent être
surprenants contre-intuitif
prendre garde que lorsqu'une victime ne
peut pas parler son corps parle il hurle
même parfois
et vous désormais
comment pourriez vous rendre visibles
les violences subies par jeanne amélie
rémy gabriel claire et tant d'autres
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]